today's topic
[Music]
you're a young man and you want to learn
avoid making mistakes
that i made um take some notes
first note young men do not
kiss and tell shut the [ __ ] up
about whatever kind of bedroom
activities you engage in
all right and stay vague if you have to
say something stay vague
keep it to yourself all right there's
nothing
to brag about to your friends oh you man
back this that's not cool p
it makes you look lame it might seem
cool now
trust me in a couple years you're not
going to be feeling that way
and i'll tell you this when you don't
learn to not kiss and tell what ends up
happening is that you build a negative
reputation
listen when someone chooses to sleep
with you that is something that you
share with them that is an intimate
moment that you share with them
bless you respect that sense of privacy
that extends to nudes as well i think
there's nothing more pathetic
than men who decide to share and it's
also very illegal
but besides the fact that it's illegal
yes just morally it's reprehensible
if i knew a man that was doing that i'd
be like bro check yourself that's just
i wanna i don't even wanna my friends
would never do that and i would not
associate with people who think it's
cool to do that
you got something great that's for you
and that
someone sends you a nude i believe it's
a little secret you
you sharing the news that someone gave
to you
and calling that person xyz actually
tells
more not about the person that sends you
the nude but tell us more about you
it just shows that you have a fragile
eagle that you need an ego boost to show
people that you were with somebody
and that they sent you something rough
it makes you look lame
that's what now today's video is
sponsored by adam and eve there's going
to be times where you need some extra
equipment
extra items for all your bedroom
activities as such
if you use promo code abba you get 50
off on one item as well as free shipping
to anywhere within the us
or canada it's a good deal i mean you
got a little extra extra something to
show them to bet you guys saying
keep it spicy right two learn to be
brave
what's your definition of brave here's
what i'll say
as a as an individual encountering fear
is inevitable
you will be in situations where you
would be afraid
and fear cannot be stopped so i always
tell people don't try to fight and
control things you can't stop
what you can control however is your
response to fear
and i define bravery not as the absence
of fear
but understanding acknowledging your
fear and persevering regardless
what is the difference between fear and
stupidity
huh because sometimes people are gonna
mistake
bravery with like yeah i was brave
no bruh that was stupid that was hella
stupid well i mean
sometimes it's just hindsight do you dig
what i'm saying
sometimes you got to make mistakes you
know what i mean
failure does not determine whether
something was stupid or not sometimes
you got to just take that risk and if
you fail you fail
but being brave will always always in
the long term
give you the best outcome possible but
by being brave you ensure that you're
always going to be put in situations
that will be
outside of your comfort zone you're
going to learn you're going to grow
and you're not going to stay stagnant
you're going to test your character
you're going to test your values as a
result of being put in these situations
being brave ensures that
who you are will be cemented by
experience
rather than ideas does that make sense
next time when fear does come
you'll know to recognize it you'll learn
to acknowledge it and you'll learn to
move past it right away okay it's going
down
listen a crisis comes i'm good to go how
we moving
what do we need to do because i've been
through it so many times i've taken the
most dumb risk you can imagine
oh we know we've taken some risks
we we've been in the ghosts we
have here's what happened
civil war broke out around us and we
were able
to leave a country literally and we had
to walk through
what i would consider semi-war
okay but we kept a calm face and we
understood that we needed to do what was
necessary
in order to get out of it but if there
was i'm telling you as a man yeah
people will often look at you in moments
of crisis to lead them to a better place
or to at least be the person who
supports others who lead them to a
better place
so you need to have your together so be
brave all right
be brave take those take those difficult
decisions don't
don't always choose the easy route be
brave and do what's scary
okay the third thing learn to say
no learn to assert your boundaries
asserting your control
is not only sexy and endearing to the
opposite sex but it is
paramount to your mental health because
once you're able to assert
your boundaries learn to say no to
things that you don't want to accept
you create your own sense of kingdom and
i'm not talking about your room in your
mama's
habit i'm talking about up here and
relationships
i'm talking about this they can't take
that away from you once you know how to
assert yourself and you're going to
to live by that then you can protect
that at all times
if there's some things that some of your
friends or your acquaintances or the
people that you see are acting a certain
way
and you're not comfortable with that you
have to be able to be like hey you know
what
if that happens again i will leave
yep i will drop all of that because i'm
not comfortable with this and that and
that
and by doing so trust me by doing so
you're going to be called many names and
people are not
they're you're going to smell the gas
because the gas lighting is going to
come
oh you're crazy that's nothing oh you're
chill relax it ain't no
no no no it ain't a thing to you but i'm
not
i'm not having that and this is not
happening
and if you want this to keep on going
that has to stop
yep it happens again i'm out and once
you say that
go with your word the next time it
happens
yep and i'll even go as far to say this
as you learn to search your own
boundaries and to respect them
you also learn how to respect other
people's boundaries because one who has
mastered over his dominion
does not feel the need to invade
everyone else's
develop a code and live by it a man must
have a code a set of rules and values
that you will
die for because it makes it a lot easier
to live
you talk about the bro code nah but
that's poetic i'm not gonna lie when i
wrote this i was like well that's a good
line
hold on a man must have a code a set of
rules and values that you will die for
because it makes it a lot easier to live
that's poor that's that morning a little
headache damn [ __ ] yeah yo
it starts snapping nope
i i forgot this i die for values okay i
die for coach yeah
i'm coding okay coding for kids
programming
is this legal i don't know chris dalia
okay
all right we're gonna stop that i think
uh developer code what does that mean
it means that okay so what you're doing
right now that's a code
yeah that's a code that you live by
those rules sure sure
sure you know for me there's just a
certain set of values that i have to
live by
a certain sense of compassion uh for my
neighbors towards the elderly
um towards the weak that those are
things that are super important to me
like if i see it in front of me i have
to act
i'm compelled to not because someone
tells me or not because i'm gonna feel
guilty but because within me i think
it's important to protect those people
right
um it's important for me to live a life
of integrity
why because if i don't i don't sleep
well my consciousness eats at me
it's so embedded in who i am um that if
i
if i if i lie for money if i lie for
you know um job opportunities or if
i i i hide who i am in order to
gain something like it's just not good
for my mental health like that's how
embedded in me is it's important for me
um so how do you develop a code well
you do it through learning you know you
do it through learning you do through
observing other people's ethics and you
and you
assimilate and you try to be like do i
want this do i like this idea
and you're like yeah let me have that
and then from there
you're going to be tested right you're
going to be faced with situations where
you're going to have to choose between
your ethics
and whatever whatever it is
and what you choose will determine
whether or not these things
become cemented in your being there are
just things that i cannot do in life
point number five be patient with
yourself
you are young you are growing you will
not
stop growing and things will get easier
more clear
much more simple but it's going to take
time
as young man we're full of testosterone
we want to take over we want to be the
top
dog we just left our mom's house we want
to do all this stuff
take your time
the level of comfort i feel within
myself is nothing
like when i when i now it's great but
when i was 22
naps when i was 18 non-existent it was a
progressive thing
understand some people may progress
faster some people may progress slower
it's not a race
you're gonna have your time it's not a
race don't rush it
be patient with yourself all right
especially for men like we peak in our
30s i mean
we peak in our 30s i can assure you
my life is not going in terms of
finances in terms of dating prospects in
terms of
life stability all that stuff everything
is peaks around this time and it's like
that for most dudes
all right so be patient point number six
learn to listen all right i think as
young men
we determined that what it means to be a
man is to be assertive and to lead all
the time
but what you have to understand is that
you may not necessarily have the
qualities
or the knowledge yeah or the skill set
to lead
so take the time to learn sometimes
people think you assert yourself by
talking a lot but other times i'm
telling you your silence
can be just as assertive as you're
talking
your ability to listen intently and
assimilate information
is just as important as actually
conveying information
especially positions of leadership
leadership is not mostly about talking
it's actually more about listening
people think there's a difference
between because your orders are not
based off what you want to see
your orders on the information that
you've taken in your ability to listen
to analyze information and then provide
orders that is the first step
the first step is not to talk it ain't
this it's this
it's this and then it's processing so
learn to develop your listening skill
the listening part is not so much just
for the people that you consider
higher than you listen to the people
around you because you know everybody
can teach you
that anybody can teach you something
yeah so it's it's that it's a
multi-level thing multi-level
it's not just the people that you
consider higher point number seven avoid
debt
i'm gonna speak about this in a
financial term as you're going to be
growing through life
especially around my age i know a lot of
men who are shackled by a lot of
financial debt
in fact it's almost drowning for them
and one thing my mom
taught me that i think was pretty much
you know life-changing for me she said
don't buy anything you can't pay for
outright you got a credit card
that's fine but don't pay for anything
that you can't pay for at the end of the
month your mom said that to you
yeah yeah she she made that very clear
and i think
like my mom had some terrible messages
but that was definitely one of the best
ones
okay i'm gonna be 100 with y'all and i'm
so grateful for that because it set me
up in the future when i
had more sense of what i wanted to do
and be when i was more comfortable
myself
like cool i want to do this i wasn't
shackled
by bad decisions i had made financially
then that we're going to follow my
credit history and all that stuff
so my recommendations theologists avoid
debt i know it might be tough there
might be a school but
maybe there's situations where it does
make sense if you're ready to make that
decision but if you're going to take on
debt
make sure you know what that means make
sure you understand the ramifications of
that long term
and you're willing to take that risk
because if you're not
do not take on that debt do not take on
more than what you know you can handle
understand the risks that you're taking
on cool point number eight
seek out a mentor if you don't have one
right if you don't have a father figure
or brother or whatever
uncle i don't coach whatever seek one
out
all right i know it might seem like a
weak thing as a man to be like
but trust me there's a lot of men who
are ready to provide you with that
insight
ready to provide you with their time and
energy go seek them out
because how do you seek a mentor well
there actually are a whole bunch of
organizations in most cities where if
you want to be linked up with a
mentorship
there are programs but oftentimes you'll
probably actually already know one you
just
don't actually make that extended effort
you don't have that conversation put
that name in there
yeah you're my mentor no you just no go
to the fur the other point that we said
before listen just listen
sometimes it's someone way older that
you respect it you're like yo listen i
got some questions about this and like
yeah sure youngblood asked me the
questions you know if you know somebody
ask him a question you don't have to
sign a dotted line be like hey [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i'm gonna see
you every tuesday i'm gonna be i'm gonna
be that i know that when i'm gonna be
old yeah i'm gonna beat that dude yeah
what you guys what was that
was it well yeah wait what
all our youtube fans are looking at you
like you're already that old uncle yeah
have you been that dude yeah i've been
preachers out here
i'll be that old
[Music]
this next point kind of ties into the
last one it's um develop a space to
convi
to confide in and ask questions have
real conversations
get your homies together yeah and if
your friends can't do it then get rid of
them and find friends where you can
confide it
all right listen i i am an autonomous
person i can handle most of my problems
by myself
but having a space where i felt
comfortable to share my some of my
burdens every now and then
and to be able to also to listen to
other brothers and be able to take on
theirs and
also realize oh you're dealing with some
of the same problems i ain't okay well
just knowing that there's a sense of
camaraderie camaraderie for men
is so so important so when i'm telling
you guys you need that
let me rephrase that i'm not gonna say
you need it you're gonna you can live
and die without it
but life just is not the same without it
listen
i was raised with women around me i got
more women friends and man friends and
let me tell you
you set up that group when we have all
these people
and we're talking about real things you
know
not yo when we gonna smoke next when we
going to go to the clicking some
entrance
when we no real stuff not not that
yeah because there's a difference
between you know what hey i got
something
we could bro i got nothing i want to see
some new yeah you want to see some new
you know that last girl that's not none
of that
issues that man go through listen i got
i don't even
i don't think i didn't have that i had a
couple
i had that before i had a couple of
friends and stuff like that but i
didn't know i really it was really
important and i don't go with you about
how old are you i'm i'm 38 i'm 38.
but when you set that up and like yo i
didn't know
i didn't know i needed that even my girl
was like my girl was like
i'm i'm glad i'm glad you have that
group
i'm i'm really glad you have that group
and you guys are able to talk and i'm
like yo i'm gonna just talk with the
boys
yeah you do that cause what she talks
with her girls all the time
people that go through the same stuff as
you do i really didn't realize how
important it was it's a weird analogy
but it still is why do you think you
have a
a meetings because people they
understand their struggles that they go
through
and that's why they get into groups and
they can talk about it without judgment
because they go through the same thing
so it's a bit the same thing as that i
didn't even know i needed that
yeah but and i do yep and the last one i
would say is this
be kind um be compassionate
and and think of your community you know
i think
especially for me as i grow older like
the idea of community matters so much to
me
the idea of being part of something and
and providing and
having roots in there and and trying to
cement that and
and nurture that it means something to
me i think is
men i think we
we do have a desire to want to protect
and i think that protection extends to
our friends and family
but sometimes it can extend beyond that
if you have the capabilities if you've
built the infrastructure to be able to
handle your friends and family sometimes
you want to go beyond that
and
what i would tell you is that there's a
sense of fulfillment that you feel
when you know you alleviate the burdens
of the people around you
i know it's always happened for my
friends and family and it feels great
because i have those problems with them
but even for the people who are not part
of that
and even with our fans you know the idea
that we're
we're nurturing something for some of
you guys that that really like helps you
get through situations
that means something to me it makes me
want to do this work
right so so i would tell you whatever
you're going into as a young man
have that idea of kindness and
compassion and understanding like yo you
want to nurture something in other
people you want to help them
to be able to protect themselves and to
protect others
and so you foster better communities in
that sense
be a pillar be a pillar for the others
around you
be the be the [ __ ] the thing that
keeps up the shelter that keeps people
safe
right i feel like honestly that's a role
that i want to have in life
that is the role i want to have for my
friends and my family and my community
and i think a lot of other people want
that as well so so live your life
on most days by those ideas yeah
so when you're going through and stuff
and like yo is this is this going
against those ideas is this my actions
right now
hurting my community and my am i acting
in a way that's really harmful in that
sense
question that you know and uh
that's maybe more of an advanced idea
but it is something that even i
at 30 right now and just developing a
little bit more and more
um so yeah i think that was pretty much
my 10 tips did you have a tip that
you wishing you was a young man when you
said
be able to say no i was just thinking
about something you know i was not even
talking about like asserting yourself
but
on top of that being able to say no
is is power
you know what that is you know what that
is what is it
that's just discipline oh i see what
you're saying
yeah it's it's
that wish yeah i i learned that
along the way because i was a kid kid
and someone was able to
stop being so impressionable by people
here you're
being able to say no what's great you
know what i'll say to you about
discipline discipline is a sense of
freedom
you know there's this idea that like if
you restrict yourself
you're there for living a life in
a prison not really what's happening
with discipline is that you're not
giving in to your urges
you're aspiring to a greater ideal and
so when you're shackled by your urges
you're actually not in control of your
being
you're literally giving yourself over to
whatever whims and
things that happen to you you are a
vessel
for everything happening to you you are
not actually in control
discipline is freedom because it gives
you the
choice to therefore make say i will do
this or i
won't so yes in that sense
i definitely agree with preach learning
to say no to whether it's women whether
it's
substances whether it's you know prime
whatever it might be
discipline is definitely super you could
put it at that point
yeah yeah yeah no no well this is uh
it for today's video hope you guys
enjoyed and uh yeah that's it
[Music]
me